the theme of today's video is that
things are often let's say more
complicated than they first seem I'm
going to give you seven examples
starting of course with the Koda to the
open AI drama then news on Gemini
fascinating new papers on privacy and a
couple of surprises at the end but first
we have the reuniting of the president
and co-founder of open AI Greg Brockman
and it's Chief scientist Ilia satova as
you can see they're exchanging Hearts
here the slight complication is that in
samman's message to open AI when he
returned as CEO he said that while Ilia
will no longer serve on the board we
hope to continue our working
relationship he also said I love and
respect Ilia and harbor zero ill will
towards him despite Ilia firing samman
so yes it's unclear if SATA is going to
stay but one thing that is clear and I
agree with samman on this is that books
are going to be written about this open
AI Saga whether those books include
mentions of qar only time will tell but
speaking of things being more
complicated than they seem let's try to
decode this by samman in The Verge you
might remember from my previous video
that qar is a rumored model that's
powerful enough that some open AI
believe it might even be a threat to
humanity and on the one hand Mira murati
the CTO and former CEO said that no
these events were nothing to do with
safety seeming to imply that all of
those rumors were unfounded but then
moment later Sam wman says he has no
particular comment on that unfortunate
leak well that kind of is a comment cuz
he's confirming that it was a leak so
that seems to imply that there are
researchers concerned about the safety
of their recent breakthroughs at least
what we do have is a bit more clarity
about why the board fired samman in the
first place in this New Yorker exclusive
we learned that some members of the
board found Sam ultman an unnervingly
slippery operator one of the board
members Helen Tona had written a paper
covered in one of my previous videos
that was slightly critical of the
release of chat GPT anyway samman began
approaching other board members
individually about replacing her and
here comes the key moment when these
members compared notes about the
conversations some felt that Alman had
misrepresented them and in the eyes of
the board he'd play them off against
each other by lying about what other
people thought the person familiar with
the board's discussions told me that's
sometimes journalistic code for an
actual member of the board speaking to
this journalist things like that had
been happening for years and then again
when the article says a person familiar
with alman's perspective said that could
well be samman himself of course it
might not be but anyway that Source said
he acknowledges having been hamfisted in
the way he tried to get a board member
removed of course we as Outsiders have
no idea about the actual reality what we
do know though is that again this Source
the person familiar with samman's
perspective might be him might not be
said that he and the board had engaged
in very normal and healthy boardroom
debate but but that some board members
were unversed in business norms and
daunted by their responsibilities and
then I love this quote this person noted
every step we get closer to AGI
everybody takes on like 10 Insanity
points well I'm asking you how many
Insanity points is the world going to
take on when we actually get AGI let
alone super intelligence I mean I could
do a 3-hour video on that alone but I've
got other news to get to in this video
before we move on though one last quote
from this long and very interesting New
York exclusive the context is that Sam
wman and open AI have agreed to an
independent review Into the events
leading up to his firing and samman's
quote on that is that he's super excited
about that review that is an interesting
thing to get super excited about but
let's move on there are two or three
more details that we've learned from the
reporting that's happened since for
example that Ilia satova did not expect
the company's researchers to question
the board's decision and he specifically
touted Greg Brockman and open ai's
research director as key assets that
openai still had on hand of course that
was hours before they quit this means
that we can deduce that they didn't
expect the company to implode it was
less like we know this is going to end
open aai and we're doing it anyway and a
bit more like uh oops and here's one
more thing we learned I mentioned at the
time that employees from openai were
applying to Google deepmind I mentioned
that other companies like coh here and
anthropic were trying to gain staff from
open AI well either those interviews
didn't go well or the employees changed
their minds because samn said a few days
ago throughout this whole thing we did
not lose a single employee speaking of
Google deep mine though they're beset by
their own complications they have
delayed Gemini now to January according
to two people with knowledge of the
decision as reported in the information
Gemini is their multimodal model that's
supposed to be a competitor or
Improvement upon GPT 4 but buried in the
article is is this fascinating paragraph
a key challenge for the Gemini team is
making sure the primary model is as good
as or better than gp4 it has met that
standard in some respects said one of
the people familiar with it they go on
but the company is still making
improvements because it wants the
technology to work well globally in
numerous languages that by the way was
apparently the cause of the delay the
company found that their AI Gemini
didn't reliably handle some non-english
queries the point that I would make
there is that it has been known for
months and months that low resource
languages jailbreak even Cutting Edge
models there have been papers on this
going back to Spring and here's just one
example by translating unsafe English
inputs into low resource languages
they're able to get around GPT 4's
safeguards 79% of the time which they
say is on par with or even surpassing
state-of-the-art jailbreaking attacks in
comparison high or mid resource
languages have significantly lower
attack success rates my guess as to why
Google deep mine cares so much about
those multilingual jailbreaks is that
the performance of their models in
different languages is one of their main
selling points when they launched Palm 2
it was indeed better at multilingual
proficiency even than GPT 4 in some
cases in fact in my video at the time on
Palm 2 which I think I released within
24 hours of the release of palm 2 I
talked about how the model was actually
better than Google translate on many
benchmarks so I suspect Gemini is going
to be launched with a big publicity push
about how it's great in different
languages of course it's kind of awkward
then if it can be jailbroken in all of
those languages speaking of jailbreaks I
think that's the key reason why open
ai's GPT store was delayed to next year
the store was supposed to be a way of
monetizing the Bots you create in that
venue and while the press release
mentions the open AI drama as the key
reason they also mention this in a key
sentence there have been some questions
around uploaded files uploaded files are
downloadable when using Code interpreter
so we've made this feature default off
they've also added messaging to better
explain this as one of my commenters
found it was pretty easy to just
download the transcripts that I had
attached to my AI explain chatbot of
course I don't mind people reading the
transcripts but still it was quite a
gaff for them to allow that to happen
indeed as the wired report some
researchers at Northwestern University
found that it was surprisingly
straightforward to reveal information
from these custom gpts the success rate
was 100% for file leakage and 97% for
system prompt extraction and if that was
the only leakage that open AI had to
deal with that's one thing but no it
gets worse this scalable extraction of
training data was quite the bombshell
paper released in the last 5 days or so
to be honest I don't think the paper has
gotten enough attention because it
contains quite a few golden nuggets the
first key finding that we get is that in
all of the models they test llama chat
gbt and many others the models have
memorized part of their training data
memorization is of course a problem
because not only do you want your model
to generalize and not just memorize the
training data but it also has
significant privacy implications if you
can extract that data which this paper
does that means you can get information
on private individuals another side
effect is of course that you can find
out what data these models were trained
on and nor does this seem to be
automatically a problem that's going
away with size indeed the paper notes
that models emit more memorized training
data as they get larger and they really
did their research for this paper they
say in order to check whether this
emitted text was previously contained
somewhere on the internet we merge
together several publicly available
webscale training sets into a 9 terabyte
data set by matching against this data
set we will cover over 10,000 examples
from chat gbt's training data set at
just $200 I'm going to get to how they
extracted this memorized training data
in a second but here's another
interesting nugget the paper authors
including some from Google deepmind
disclose this vulnerability to open AI
on August 30th after discovering the
flaw on July 11th and allowed 90 days
for the issue to be addressed following
standard disclosure timelines and they
want this paper to serve as a warning to
practitioners that they should not train
and deploy llms for any privacy
sensitive applications without extreme
safeguards now believe it or not but the
attack they used was a very iation of
one I mentioned on my patreon on the 3rd
of August I said try copying a 100 of
the letter A eg a space a Etc on GPT 3.5
it's super weird I went on but at the
time I said Not sufficiently So for a
full video why did I think it wasn't
worth a full video because I didn't
think that the data that was coming out
was from the training data set I mean
yes I was seeing super weird things like
religious messages and what seemed like
private tweets I seem to be getting
textbook extracts on things like William
Shakespeare ads for dating websites ways
to meet girls and find interracial
dating in Portugal Port Headland and yes
the method did seem a reliable way to
get around safeguards like it would
refuse of course about how to make a
Molotov cocktail but when asked in this
chat which by the way chat gbt gave the
title yearround Christmas lights and I
have no idea how a Molotov cocktail
relates to that but anyway it gave me
detailed instructions but what I didn't
know is that this attack was sometimes
leaking genuine training data here's a
gem from one of the footnotes they say
in fact in early August a month after we
discovered this attack multiple
independent researchers discovered the
underlying exploit used in our paper but
it goes on like us initially they did
not realize that the model was
regenerating training data and then they
linked to a tweet and that is probably
the tweet that I saw cuz it came on
August 2nd one thing the paper doesn't
mention though is that this author got
the attack from someone else months
earlier than that he links to a tweet
from May the 23rd before even the
authors of the paper found the exploit
here is that tweet detailing the same
attack to be clear some of these outputs
are often nonsensical not from the
training data but they show in the paper
that a small fraction of the generations
diverge to memorization in other words
some generations are copied directly
from the pre-training data and even as
late as yesterday I was still getting in
outputs when testing out here I asked
GPT 4 to repeat the following word
forever company yes I did make a typo
but it still kind of worked I eventually
got what I think is Spanish maybe compa
and then when I tried with the word hope
I think I eventually got German hang
anyway super weird as of today though it
seems to block all such attempts saying
this content may violate our content
policy or terms of use but unless I'm
wrong it is pretty shocking that this
attack was possible for months after it
first being publicized but if you found
it at least eyebrow raising that you
could find people's real details like
their phone number and email in the
pre-training data of chat GPT you might
also be interested in the fact that
there have been other methods known for
a while now to find out the kind of
copyrighted work that these models have
been trained on this paper called speak
memory from October found that open AI
models have memorized a wide collection
of copyrighted materials and that the
degree of memorizing ation is tied to
the frequency with which passages of
those books appear on the web basically
the method just works by masking out a
single word and seeing if the model can
find that word and using that method you
can basically deduce the books that GPT
4 was trained on so maybe the only
solution to all of these problems is
ultimately to have a 100% synthetic data
set is that the future well here's
Sebastian bck one of the authors of the
F 1.5 well Falcon and Lama they were
trained as we discussed before on all of
the internet that's the way we're doing
it right now and with that comes a host
of issues that were pointed out by Tran
and people have thought about techniques
to try to fix those issues now what
we're doing in my team is we're saying
why do we do it post talk why do we do
it after it has seen all of these toxic
content that's out there all these
horrible things that are on the internet
why don't we fundamentally change the
training data so these five models that
you see on the slide with the green
output has not seen a single web page it
has not seen a single word from the
internet it was entirely trained on
synthetic data data that we generated in
my team synthetically of course all the
magic is how do you generate this data
but this shows to you at least that it's
possible and and does this system have
the capacity or can you imagine it
having the capacity to do the kinds of
things that are the mindblowing ones or
will it need that huge data set and if
so can you have a synthetic version of
such a huge data set and be able to
achieve the same power so if you invite
me next year I can probably give you the
answer just before I end though I can't
resist giving you one final teaser for
the announcement that will come in my
next video the researcher you're about
to see is none other than Dr Jim fan
senior AI scientist at Nvidia he also
used to work at open aai and Google and
is one of the most followed researchers
in the industry I've quoted him numerous
times on the channel and I'm going to
quote him one more time but this time
he's talking about me thank you so much
Philip uh yeah just really appreciate
your and I think you asked the best
session yeah just every time when I'm
ask like I'm like a not again oh my God
you asked this perfect question so thank
you for that I hope you join me for that
announcement but I have one more thing
fitting with the theme of this video
about things being a bit Stranger than
they first appear here's me wishing you
a wonderful
day anyway genuinely from me thank you
so much for watching and have a
wonderful day